[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20 Special Relativity.
So we're starting a new chapter.
In this chapter, we
talk about some aspects
of special relativity,
which are not crucially
important to understand
the concepts,
but they help you to
go a little bit deeper
in your understanding.
I hope this is
going to be useful.
So we want to talk
about the algebra
of known transformations.
So we have seen that our gamma
factor is 1 over square root
1 minus beta squared with beta
equal the relativistic velocity
v/c.
And thus, this we can rewrite
it as gamma squared minus beta
squared gamma squared
is equal to 1, OK?
So now, I would like you to
recall hyperbolic functions
sinh and cosh and cosh
squared minus sinh
squared is equal to 1.
So the form here and here
are pretty much the same.
And something squared minus
something else squared
equal to 1, OK?
Good.
So let's see how
this looks like.
As a reminder for us, the
hyperbolic functions as
defined as 1/2 e to
the x power minus
e to minus x and cosh equal to
1/2 e to x plus e to minus x.
OK?
The tangent is then
defined as a ratio.
And you can plot
those functions,
and you can see the
functional form as
given in these two diagrams.
Well, we want to come back to
those two equations looking
very much the same.
So we can define now
eta, the rapidity,
as gamma equal to hyperbolic
function cosh eta and beta
gamma equals sinh eta.
So basically, we
have this rapidity,
which is a measure on
how much the system is
boosted as being equal to
this kind of hyperbolic angle,
right?
You can then
process again, where
beta is equal to the tangents
of this hyperbolic angle.
And just remember that the
slope in our space time diagram
is 1 over the velocity.
We find that angle again now
is being called rapidity, OK?
And just as a reminder,
beta goes from minus 1 to 1,
depending on the direction
and the speed of it
is less than the speed of light.
And then eta goes from
minus infinity to infinity.
OK, so then we can rewrite
our Lorentz transformation.
Instead of writing gamma and
beta gamma and minus beta
gamma and so on,
we can write this
through the hyperbolic angle.
OK?
So you should always
ask why is this useful.
The first part is that
when we add velocities,
we found this complicated
transformation
where the new velocity is
equal to the first velocity
times the second velocity over
1 plus the product of the two
velocities.
And this is much easier now as
we can just add the velocities.
So the third velocity is equal
to the first plus the second.
This is much, much easier
to actually calculate.
And the proof of this
is coming directly
from the proof of those
hyperbolic functions here.
The second part where
this becomes useful
is when you think about the
angle in your space time
diagram.
How does this now compare
to a normal rotation?
So let's start here.
So we have a normal rotation.
We have a rotation at a angle,
and our coordinate system just
rotates by specific angle.
Let's call it phi here.
And what we do now,
we have a similar
but a hyperbolic
rotation in which
the coordinate system in our
space time diagram rotates.
All right?
In the normal rotational
case, x squared
plus y squared is invariant.
And in our Lorentz
transformation,
c squared t squared
minus x squared.
All right?
If you then have a more general
transformation, a rotation,
and Lorentz
transformation, you find
x squared plus y squared plus
z squared minus c squared
t squared [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so we have just
relabeled things,
but now we can make
use of everything
we know about
hyperbolic functions
when we think about
adding velocities.
Because the rapidity-- the
relative distance and speed
between two reference frames
is basically the angle
of the hyperbolic angle.